some breaking news about the leadership  race and that is  um Sky analysis  has it that Rishi sunak has now reached  a hundred backers which obviously means  that he has now passed the threshold  needed to make the ballot for the next  PM the nomination closes at 2PM he  hasn't declared his candidacy yet but  Sky analysis has it that he has reached  that threshold needed to make the ballot  for the next pm and that is a hundred  MPS that is so that's the latest Rishi  sunak at a hundred Boris Johnson at 48  and Penny wooden now up one she was on  19 she's at 20 now but they've got until  2 P.M to make a hundred and uh declare  their candidacy basically for the race